much has been said about amber heard in
recent weeks but what do her aquaman
co-stars really think of her keep
watching to find out
the upcoming dc movie aquaman in the
lost kingdom has hit headlines recently
not because it's a sequel to a hugely
successful movie but because of the
media firestorm surrounding amber heard
in johnny depp's very public defamation
trial right now there is a petition on
change.org to remove herd entirely from
the aquaman sequel which has garnered
millions of signatures to date the
result of one portion of the fandom
venting their feelings about the case
and heard in particular hurt herself has
claimed her breakup with depth caused
her role in the new movie to be
significantly reduced to as little as 10
minutes of screen time
i had to fight to
i fought really hard to stay in the
movie
in aquaman dolph lundgren plays king
nereus leader of the kingdom of zebel
while heard plays his daughter mira a
staunch proponent of aquaman's ascension
to the throne as well as his potential
love interest with aquaman and the lost
kingdom on the horizon lundgren was
asked what it's been like working with
his fictional daughter on set and it
definitely seems like his mind is made
up in june 2022 dolph lundgren spoke to
red line steel ceo colin wayne about
aquaman and the lost kingdom and his
experience working on the movie in doing
so he highlighted what it was like
working with amber bird on set without
bringing up the legal battle between her
and johnny depp or the verdict it
spawned the actor shared his honest
feelings about how she conducted herself
when the cameras weren't rolling
lundgren said she was great i worked
with her on the first aquaman now the
second one we shot last fall in london
she's terrific i had a great experience
with her lundgren added she's very kind
nice to the crew nice to everybody just
down to earth she had her newborn baby
with her on set with the nanny which was
kind of cute coincidentally herd's
reduced role in the second aquaman movie
is explained away due to her pregnancy
with aquaman's son making her unable to
join him on his escapades judging by
lundgren's comments it seems as if he
enjoyed working with her during the
production of both aquaman movies the
kind of connection goes a long way on
the silver screen especially when the
actors are playing members of each
other's family while it's great that
amber heard and dolph lundgren got along
just fine on the set of aquaman and its
sequel lundgren is not the only one from
the franchise with good things to say
about herd take for instance the
centerpiece of the dceu series jason
mamoa entertainment consultant catherine
arnold testified at the trial that mamoa
had fought to ensure heard wasn't
removed from the lost kingdom at the
same time when the johnny depp amber
heard trial reached a verdict mamoa made
headlines for seeming to remain neutral
instead of picking aside at least in
public arnold also testified that
director james wan had also fought hard
to keep herd attached to the lost
kingdom according to arnold both mamoa
and juan were adamant that she remained
in the movie while momoa and juan's
pleas to warner brothers seemed to have
paid off meera's screen time didn't make
it out of the negotiation process
unscathed burtis claimed that she had a
much greater role in the lost kingdom
which she says was cut down due to
public concerns regarding her
relationship with johnny depp president
of dc films walter hamada however
insists that herd's role was threatened
due to her lack of chemistry with mamoa
just the the fact that they didn't
really have a lot of chemistry together
no matter what it's clear that heard
earned herself at least a few fans
during the production of aquaman in the
lost kingdom in the form of her
colleagues and co-stars
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]